i only ever did what you asked of me
what you told me
to be and train me to do and i did it
and i did it well it's the second last
episode of the falcon in the winter
soldier but it is my personal favorite
consider this your spoiler warning from
carlos bustamante and this
is e.t cannonbismur
some of the best storytelling in this
series continues to take place
during the action scenes in the fight
between sam bucky and john walker that
kicks off this episode
does not disappoint jon is now clearly
unhinged
using the shield to threaten that death
blow we know he is capable of
we see even more inventive ways sam uses
his wings in battle
and so much of this from the visuals to
the music calls back to the cap
bucky and iron man fight in captain
america civil war plus
who doesn't like a good tag team
wrestling move as a finisher
now as effective as that all is this
quiet moment right after
tells so much of the larger story
[Music]
the look sam and bucky exchange when
bucky drops the shield at the end of the
fight
sam overcome with emotion as he's trying
to wipe the blood off of it
considering how his decisions might have
led them to this point
like seriously what do you think he's
thinking here you gotta appreciate
moments like this
it's really great stuff and great stuff
continues in this episode with a cameo
that honestly
comes out of nowhere valentina
allegra lafontaine actually it's
contessa
valentina allegra to fountain i know
it's hard
but i don't like to repeat myself so you
can just call me val
contested valentina allegra de fontaine
which is just so much fun to say
played by the one and only julia louis
dreyfus she's got a little shock of
purple in her hair so you know she's up
to no good
in the comics she's a former high level
shield agent very close to nick fury but
at one point becomes madame hydra
while also being a secret agent for the
russians
it's a busy lady anyway she knows about
the serum and the shield and yada yada
yada she gives john a business card with
nothing on it
she going around like some reverse nick
fury collecting bad guys for a team of
i don't know dark avengers also
i think we deserve an eventual dance-off
between her and zemo
speaking of zemo you'd think he'd be a
harder guy to find but nope
he's back in sokovia where he and bucky
come to a kind of understanding
before the door of melania come to take
him away where is he going
the raft of course which is a super
prison for super criminals that
never gets super broken out of at all
[Music]
and just as the dora are about to
finally bring zemo to justice for crimes
against wakanda
lucky just has to stop io and ask for a
favor
honestly these guys in their favors i
may have another favor to ask
you sharon we need your help i can't
help but feel a favor coming on
this is an interesting one though as we
will see later
in the episode now what i think it is
um leave it covered those stars and
stripes don't
mean nothing good to me
[Music]
i need to understand the title of this
episode is truth which is also the title
of the comic mini series that tells the
story
of isaiah bradley fitting then that when
sam goes to visit isaiah to get some
clarity
isaiah lays out his truth his whole
heartbreaking story
it's one of the most emotional scenes
ever in the mcu as isaiah spells out the
racial injustices he's lived through
as a super soldier for the usa see
isaiah did pretty much the same thing
steve did during the war go behind enemy
lines to rescue his fellow soldiers
but while america branded steve a hero
isaiah was incarcerated and tortured for
decades
steve came out of the ice as an avenger
isaiah barely made it out alive
his whole history and legacy erased they
will never let a black man
be captain america
and even if they did no self-respecting
black man
sam heads home to spend time with his
sister and help fix up their family boat
which proves to be a good thing for sam
sarah and the overly flirty bucky barnes
i'm back
sam and bucky patch up the boat together
and patch up their relationship
becoming the bros we always knew they'd
be though
neither of them will admit it not
necessarily as a team nope
we're not that good definitely not we're
professionals definitely
and uh we're partners co-workers
but we're also a couple guys with a
mutual friend friends now going so we're
a couple of guys
i can live with that perfect it's here
that sam discovers his truth
restoring the wilson family vote was
difficult and complicated but sam
refused to give up on it
the legacy of the shield is difficult
and complicated but sam's not giving up
on that either
standing up against the tough things
putting in the work not giving up
does not sound like captain america to
you that my friends
deserves a montage
[Music]
meanwhile carly morgenthau is in new
york city getting a plan together to
attack the global repatriation council
with the help of one george
st i mean george batrock who was on the
phone earlier with sharon carter who
i'm 99.9 confident is a power broker and
i'm pretty sure
you agree with me anyway this is all
leading to a big showdown in new york
where i'm sure we'll colina's gift to
sam
that favor that bucky called in it's
gonna come in handy
spoiler alert it's his new captain
america uniform
and what of the old new captain america
well he's getting ready to fight for the
name
and he's gonna bring his homemade shield
with him which i'm pretty sure is not
made of vibranium so couldn't bucky just
like smash it to bits
with his actual vibranium arm he
remembers to use it
whatever we got a whole week before we
find out what did you think of this
episode
is there another surprise cameo in store
for us next time will sam and bucky
finally admit that they're a team let's
talk about it in the comments below
thanks for watching everyone
i'll see you next time
you